sure so broadly there are two kinds of
systems in the world there are many
party systems in there to party systems
and our English cousins both England
Canada Australia India tend to have
majority rule elections rather than
proportional elections and that tends to
leave them to have to sort of competing
parties so in England you know it's been
you know since the 20s that I that
anything anybody other than labor or the
Conservatives have have formed the
government and gotten the prime minister
in the cabinet and so on and so in that
way it's very much like ours and they
have problems very much like ours as
well there's one lesson to learn from
them and that is that the the two
parties at various times in the history
recent history were criticized for being
too extreme the Conservatives under
Thatcher the Labour Party until the
coming of Gordon Brown and in his
predecessor blocking on his name right
now and and what they did was they move
they they took a much more moderate
stance within the range of opinion
within the Labour Party took a much more
moderate stance and that's what's
happening on the Conservative Party a
more moderate leadership even within the
same range a less extreme in a more
moderate leadership has has softened
some of the edges otherwise it's a
system in many ways very similar to ours
and the degree of differences are really
quite similar between the two parties if
you go to other systems in which there
are multiple parties it's odd but it
still tends to break down that two
parties generate most of the leadership
of the system even though there are
multiple parties around so for example
in Israel which has
election laws that should lead to the
largest number of parties and indeed
there are quite a large number of
parties in that system for many years
labor and the could were the only source
of prime ministers leaders of the of the
country and they took opposite positions
and it looked kind of like a two-party
system embedded in a and a multi-party
system in which there were many people
had voices in the Knesset there there
Congress but only two were effectively
governing the country
not not not easily right and not in the
short run the principal so the principal
problem is that is not it so we had two
things that happen one of them was just
sorting I talked about Southern
Democrats essentially you know in the
gained Republican Party in some sense
that's just taking you know members of
Congress who were painted bloom we
repainted them red and in New England
you just did the reverse you know Reggie
painted blue but but and that's just a
restoring and that's fine and everything
would be you know much easier if that
was the only thing that happened the
thing that got more problematic was that
it became harder and harder for
moderates to win elections and so not
only did you cert people differently in
two reds and blues but you move them
apart and so you left you let you took
out a range for moderates it's very very
few moderates now that's why people are
so focused on for example people like
Olympia Snowe she's one of the few you
know Republicans from the basically
Democratic era area and thus has the
kind of appeal that can go you know she
can win elections as a Republican in
what might otherwise be a Democrat area
because she's one of the few people
there in the center and there and
they're just so few of them that's
that's been the difficult part the
question is how would you how would we
get a valuable center back and that's a
very difficult question to to figure out
the difference between the 60s and now
and another definitely sixties and now
was that Republicans and Democrats
divided on some issues other issues
they're all intermingled and you know
Republicans and Democrats from the same
side opposite sides all mixed up and
they were not partisan issues now
virtually every issue is partisan ed and
that that it extends to virtually
everything that comes up as a partisan
twist to it is is very difficult and we
can't
you know also forget the presentation of
issues and that's you know if you think
back to the 60s and 70s news was Walter
Cronkite you know and he talked to
everybody now the network news is a much
less significant factor it's not
summarized by a Walter Cronkite kind of
figure and people have their own news to
listen to and it's as polarized as the
rest of the world there's a very
difficult thing as very took up see how
to unwind it except if new issues come
come up at do cut across party lines
that would break open some of the sort
of rigidities we currently have and
allow for some movement to come up that
provides for the possibility of at least
some degree of overlap between the two
parties some common ground between the
two parties some way in which you could
begin to see the value of bipartisan as
well as purely partisan politics